happy junetieth everybody I hope you're
doing well hope you're preparing for
junity first
which will complete the tridum of the
Sacred Feast of Juneteenth
and many of you probably had never heard
of Juneteenth before the Liberals
invented it five minutes ago but that is
not stopping even many conservatives
from embracing the holiday and joining
in on the pretense that Juneteenth is
not only a real thing but a very good
thing
I have here an article from the Antioch
Herald happy Juneteenth a celebration of
Freedom brought to you by the Republican
Party
now if you're Washington Times right
wing Washington Times Juneteenth a
celebration in honor of the gop's
greatest accomplishment
greatest one ever and then I have here
Fox News the
formerly conservative cable channel Fox
News why Juneteenth is as American as
the 4th of July Juneteenth unites
Americans by celebrating the end of
slavery of course
it doesn't do any of that
Juneteenth is not traditionally American
certainly doesn't unite people and it
doesn't Mark the end of slavery
either in the Emancipation Proclamation
or in the 13th Amendment it doesn't Mark
the end of anything it marks the day
that the mailman made it to some random
part of Texas and told the locals that
Lincoln had freed some of the slaves two
and a half years prior virtually no one
in the country had heard of it until a
few years ago when white liberals
started pretending that it was a really
important day to black people virtually
none of whom had ever heard of it either
and then because the white people
thought the black people really cared
about it everybody started pretending
that it was a thing and now it is a
Federal holiday whatever obscure local
tradition Juneteenth is based on has
little if anything to do with the
current holiday which liberals created
three years ago and named crucially the
Juneteenth National Independence Day
why did they do that in order to replace
the old independence day which is the
fourth of July
even today
even the most Ardent observers of
Juneteenth will struggle to tell you
exactly what the day commemorates
this ambiguity is by Design the point is
emphatically not to Mark anything in
particular it's not to celebrate
emancipation or freedom
the point is to insist that emancipation
never really took place that it has not
and never will be completed that it is a
constant process of Revolution to
overthrow the oppression and deceit of
our political order and National myths
that's the point the whole point of
Juneteenth is to be an anti-independence
day for an anti-American Nation it's the
same subversive claptrap that the libs
peddle every chance they get which would
be bad enough
but to add insult to injury a sizable
group of sweet Dopey gullible
conservatives are going along with it
as if our cooperation with this
contrived nonsense we'll finally get the
libs to stop calling us evil and racist
and as is always the case with
conservative capitulation
not only is this not going to work but
left unchecked the revolution will
continue
more and more radically until we finally
celebrate independence from our very
country and culture I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we have a
little later I'm sorry to report a
Southern California high school teacher
giving a lesson on pleasing and orifice
that really should not be pleased I
we're going to heavily edit it you know
this is a family show we're going to
keep it PG okay but we'll get to it
because a lot of conservatives I think
are having the wrong reaction to this
disgusting clip so we'll get to that a
little bit first though
we've got to stick around with these
squishy conservatives these gullible
Center kind of liberal squishy people
Juneteenth is for conservatives who want
to play pretend
the Liberals invent Juneteenth or more
or less if they take some random tiny
local tradition and turn it into
something completely different at the
national level and we all have to
pretend that it's a real thing and the
whole point of the holidays obviously to
be an anti-independence day it's why
it's two weeks before independence day
that's why it founds the nation in a
very different way it views the the
trajectory of The American Nation in a
very different way than the traditional
Independence Day would
the old independence day is founded on
this idea that there is a fixed human
nature there's certain truths
unalienable rights that God endows us
with and we're going to pursue those
Eternal truths the the new Independence
Day Juneteenth it says no there's not
there was the Emancipation Proclamation
that was a little earlier there's the
13th Amendment that's a little later and
but even the 13th Amendment didn't
really get rid of slavery because there
was Jim Crow later and even Jim Crow
didn't really get rid of slavery because
there was redlining and there was I
don't know there's now there's mass
incarceration that's slavery according
to the libs and so it's never over it's
never over America is always bad
it's always very oppressive we always
have to reject the past we've got to
feel a crisis in the present we've got
to just run into an uncertain liberal
future where they tell us eventually
eventually we'll we'll find Utopia
and there are conservatives who want to
pretend that that's a good thing like
that's a win
oh they don't realize what the Democrats
don't realize is they're the real
racists you see and so what they don't
realize is the Republicans actually won
the Civil War and it's the Republicans
or the good party they don't realize
that those dopes we'll show them
Juneteenth it's a republican holiday
okay all right you're not convincing
anybody but if that makes you feel
better at night okay fine and it's this
same kind of play pretend make believe
that everything is okay and that the
Republicans we're really we're really
winning here we're we're seriously equal
Partners In This American political
project it's not that the liberal
establishment dominates everything no no
we we're playing fair and square here
it's those kind of guys
who we're now seeing really go after or
say Donald Trump it's those kind of guys
who were seeing really go after the the
populist element in the GOP it's guys
like ASA Hutchinson who is furious about
the Trump campaign
not I'm sure he's Furious for a lot of
reasons but one thing he's Furious about
is the single most defensible part of
the Trump campaign namely the
observation that the Department of
Justice is being weaponized against
conservatives the whole concept of the
that so many republican leaders adopting
that this is the weaponization of the
justice department and I think they've
made some bad decisions I can certainly
disagree with many of the decisions
they've made particularly Jim Comey and
some of his in reference to Hillary
Clinton but in terms of the overall
charge of weaponization of the justice
department look at Donald Trump he's
already declared that he if he's elected
president he's going to appoint a
special prosecutor to go after the Biden
family that's called a weaponization of
the justice department and so let's back
off of these accusations and let's get
back to being the party of the rule of
law of the justice system supporting law
enforcement and equal application law
but you just admitted the Justice
Department's being weaponized
the first part of that statement ASA
Hutchinson admits yeah I look I'm not
happy with the things Jim Comey did in
particular vis-a-vis Hillary Clinton and
well what does that imply well I don't I
don't necessarily agree about the doj
letting Hillary off the hook for a much
more egregious version of the crime that
Donald Trump allegedly committed and of
course you know the doj cooking up a
completely fake narrative a hoax
alleging that he colluded with the
Russians to try to destroy his
presidential campaign from the doj and
then try to undermine his entire duly
elected Administration and sure maybe I
don't I don't support now I'm just
putting words in his mouth maybe I don't
support the fact that the doj is going
to let BLM terrorists who burn Federal
courthouses off the hook meanwhile they
throw Midwestern grannies who crack the
chorus light in the capital rotunda into
solitary confinement without charges may
be okay I know but
but
if we acknowledge all those unfortunate
truths
well then we might weaponize the justice
department too so let's just let's just
what let's just play pretend
that's what he said he's saying yes the
doj is being weaponized by democrats
against Republicans consistently it's
happening right now the majority of
Americans according to a Harvard Harris
poll say that the indictments of Donald
Trump are election interference by the
Democrats that's all true but let's
pretend it's not happening
because if we acknowledge that it's
happening then we have a responsibility
to do something about it which means
that we're going to have to insist upon
our political principles in the
government which of course we should
it's politics right pilot politics is
what we do with in the government but
with for many decades now we've
pretended that that somehow isn't the
case that the government is totally
neutral and doesn't have any substantive
political commitments and so if we do
that
Why by golly
we're going to have to acknowledge that
there are some serious problems with our
structure and that the Liberals have a
lot more power
than the squishy Republicans previously
admitted
let's just be nice guys
because if we do all that then I can't
go on CNN anymore you know then they're
going to call me like racist or
something let's just better
just to keep our heads in the sand and
play pretend
I don't think we should play pretend I
think we got to be honest we got to talk
to one another
when you want to talk to your friends
you got to check out pure talk right now
go to puretalk.com Knowles one company
that I'm very proud to stand behind a
company that's proud to stand behind us
in our country
Pure Talk veteran owned with a 100
American Workforce they share our
beliefs that is why Pure Talk is the
official cell phone wireless provider of
the daily wire but that is not the only
reason
Pure Talk also happens to be the most
Dependable 5G Network in the US they're
a top tier provider at a fraction of the
cost of those other companies you know
those companies ATT Verizon T-Mobile
companies that do not care about you or
what you believe mix and match your
plans to fit every person in your family
choose from talk text and 5G data for
just 20 bucks a month all the way up to
unlimited data with a mobile hotspot
just 55 a month I guarantee that's less
than you're paying for that right now
you vote with how you spend your money
stop supporting woke wireless companies
that do not support you go to
puretalk.com Knowles you get great
coverage and save while you're doing it
go to puretalk.com Knowles you'll save
an additional 50 off your first month
because they actually value you that is
puretalk.com
Wireless buy Americans for Americans
some conservatives are sick of playing
pretend
some thousands of conservatives
conservatives Catholics just showed up
outside of Dodger Stadium because you
know we had previously mentioned that
the Dodgers were going to honor a
an actual satanic drag troop a
Blasphemous sacrilegious satanic drag
troupe whose entire raise on debt is to
mock our Lord Jesus Christ
that group was being honored at Dodger
Stadium they're called The Sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence so they mock not
only our Lord but they mock nuns who
worship our Lord and so the Dodgers
initially said okay we probably
shouldn't honor the satanic drag group
and then later on they said no actually
we should I always should sorry I forgot
our national religion as the rainbow
okay yeah we're gonna we're gonna honor
the satanic drag troop and so thousands
of Catholics turned up outside
and and protested you can see there's
lots of great videos
and unlike when the Liberals show up in
protest they didn't burn anything down
they didn't make the place look
disgusting they just
they just held up signs and stopped this
kind of hate
believe believe in Jesus you know really
nice basic stuff holding up beautiful
banners beautiful pictures of Our Lord
crucifixes
they're just man I love conservatives
Christians so much it just even when
they're taking to the streets they're
just orderly put together
it looked nice
record but they're showing up on mass I
mean if you were a big lib
and you were going to the Dodgers game
you would probably be surprised that
there are even that many Catholics in
Southern California that is a show
of numbers and power and it's something
that the American people need to start
doing a little bit more because
increasingly you're seeing a Divergence
of opinion between the people and the
elite
the big Divergence of opinion that we're
seeing now is not so much left versus
right or Republican versus Democrat it's
people versus Elite that's how you're
seeing the emergence of populist
candidates like Donald Trump like Robert
Kennedy Jr
we're kind of Crossing party lines in a
way that we haven't seen in the last few
Decades of American politics you're
seeing the the deplorables the
irredeemable people you know the ones
the bitter clingers that Obama and
Hillary Clinton made fun of those people
don't neatly fit exactly into Republican
or Democrat they're moving much more in
the Republican Camp right now
because the Democrats have now become
the party of the elite
so we've got the numbers on our sides on
a whole host of issues I mean to use
just this example that the drag queen
stuff and the anti-catholic hate
the American people are overwhelmingly
on our side but because we don't have
that much power anymore because a small
number of elite liberals control the
political process now it's it's unclear
how how much influence our our numbers
are actually going to get us so we've
got to show up
that that does matter I was reminded of
the covid vaccines do you remember what
the coveted vaccines
Joe Biden said I'm not going to have a
vaccine mandate I'm not going to have a
vaccine mandate I'm not gonna have a
vaccine mandate okay there's a mandate
and how did that happen
because Biden was waiting fauci was
waiting for the number of people who had
already received one shot of the vaccine
to reach a significant threshold that
there wouldn't be total pushback so then
the moment when it was just 10 of people
had gotten the vaccine
Biden knew that a federal mandate was a
losing proposition
and 20 then 30 then 40 then once you get
enough people all of a sudden you say
okay now we've got it
same thing with fauci during the the
run-up to the vaccine he was asked what
percentage of people need to be
vaccinated to achieve herd immunity and
he said oh now listen here listen here I
think the total percentage is 70 one day
with 70 one day was 80 one it was 60 it
kept moving and found she was asked wait
hold on why does this keep moving and he
admitted he said
I'm paraphrasing here but he said
something to the effect of because look
part of this is politically publicly
I've got to convince people to get the
vaccine so we moved that we adjust the
thresholds a little bit to do that okay
the numbers really matter the enthusiasm
really matters if we show these guys
that we mean business they are going to
back off at least for a time now
speaking of vaccines and speaking of
Robert Kennedy Jr
he's making some waves now the way you
know that Robert Kennedy Jr is making
serious waves against Joe Biden is one
he's polling around 19 or 20 percent
against him which is pretty insane for a
quote-unquote fringe candidate who's
running against the incumbent
but the other reason that you know that
he's starting to make some serious
Headway is that the liberal
establishment's going after him so Bobby
Kennedy Jr
he lived in the town I lived in growing
up or like one town over
so I I've been aware of Bobby Kennedy Jr
for most of my life and he's a liberal
lawyer
environmentalist lawyer he he got really
focused on the vaccine issue and was
mocked for it now he's not mocked quite
as much for it because people saw the
negative effects of some of these
vaccines during covid and so now he
seems like a much more
anti-establishment figure
the guy always got really great press
the Press treated this guy like royalty
for most of my life
because he's a Kennedy and now all of a
sudden that he seems to be a threat to
Joe Biden and the liberal establishment
all of a sudden you're seeing these
headlines about decades-old misdeeds of
Bobby Kennedy Jr he's a Kennedy okay
he's lived a colorful life these guys uh
you know they're not the most buttoned
up family in America just you know look
look at his uncles look at it look at
his pretty much his whole family okay
and RFK Jr is no exception to that
my question is just uh why now why now
are you covering scandals from 10 years
ago 20 years ago oh because you gave him
a pass when he was a reliable if
eccentric Democrat but now they
threatens you in any way you're going to
try to destroy his life I am I am not
a big fan of the Kennedys I'm I'm not a
an old school liberal or something I'm
not one of these people who says boy if
Jack Kennedy were alive today he'd be a
republican I don't I guess maybe maybe
he would probably he wouldn't but I
don't know I'm not a classical liberal
I'm not a 1960s a liberal I'm just a
conservative so I'm I don't really fall
in into the thrall of of the Kennedys
but I tell you
if there were some way
to see a trump Kennedy ticket
it would probably do very very well and
it's not totally out of the question
and the reason it's not totally out of
the question is in part because of the
time that we're living in
what do Trump and Kennedy have in common
they're both for large parts of their
careers Skeptics of the vaccines they're
both now derided and detested by the
political establishment they're both
celebrity rock stars within their own
parties in social media who have been
sort of ostracized from them now
and now they're both considered to be
champions of the people
so as populism Rises and blurs the lines
between left and right
there's a case for putting those two
guys together even though Kennedy's got
all sorts of terrible opinions on guns
and abortion and all the rest of it
you you could see a case for that to be
made and it would be the craziest one
yet if a Kennedy were the GOP vice
presidential candidate that would be
completely wildly make people's heads
explode he's pulling very well among
Democrats right now
could it happen
probably not
but it is probably Kennedy's Best Shot
right now given who he is and it's a
reminder too that
populism doesn't look like you think it
does from a a movie or a novel or
something like that
it's it's not usually just some random
Yokel who crops up out of nowhere and
leads a popular revolution these guys
are both very very wealthy celebrities
who
seem like unexpected figures you know
the idea that a billionaire playboy from
New York is going to lead the
conservative Resurgence in America that
was that always seemed wild the idea
that Kennedy is going to lead the
anti-establishment faction of the
Democrats seems a little a little crazy
but but big political changes almost
driven by pretty well-funded political
minorities
it's not totally out of the question now
speaking of patriotism you're probably
going to want to check out my Patriot
Supply right now go to prepare
withnolls.com I'd love that URL in a
world filled with uncertainty it is
crucial to be ready for whatever comes
your way whether that's a natural
disaster a sudden emergency or
unforeseen circumstances having a
reliable food storage system can provide
you with peace of mind and the assurance
that you and your loved ones will be
well taken care of right now my Patriot
Supply is offering major savings on
their popular four-week emergency food
kit to help you stay prepared for
anything go to preparewithnolls.com grab
this special price before it ends that
your four-week emergency food kit
provides over 2 000 calories each day
for optimal strength and energy in
stressful situations you can enjoy a
wide variety of my Patriot Supply and
can customize your supply they offer an
ultimate breakfast kit a mega protein
kit with real meat and even a
gluten-free kit the best part is each
meal is delicious has a shelf life of 25
years do not wait for disaster to strike
before taking action invest in your
safety and well-being by securing your
food storage today prepare with
knowles.com get major savings on your
four-week emergency supply kit prepare
with knowles.com prepare with
knowles.com
the greatest interview show on the
internet many people are talking about
it yes or no man it's Grand return this
past weekend it was it was captivating
people laughed people cried it featured
the political and physical giant that we
all know and love Charlie Kirk you do
not want to miss the episode here is
just a taste of the stiff drinks and
spicy questions
my back and knee pain have greatly
improved by ignoring infomercials
[Music]
here's some more good news the yes or no
game is now back in stock baby you can
go to dailywire.com shop get your game
today the games go fast yes or no is
hands down the best way to add some
excitement to your parties challenge
your friends and Family's knowledge
delve into the most thought-provoking
topics of our time it's sold out every
time we've restocked and we always
increase the supply of the restock and
then it sells out very quickly yet again
so get yours now right now daily
wire.com shop to order yes or no
today
speaking of Democrats in RFK Jr
a majority of Democrats want Joe Biden
to debate Bobby Kennedy Jr right now
this is according to a Convention of
States action Trafalgar group survey
57 and a half percent of Democrats
believe Biden should debate RFK Jr
this is a clear majority another 31.7
things they should not debate and 10.8
percent say that they are unsure
Kennedy's Rising
just as it took that billionaire
celebrity to bring populism to the GOP
it might well take a Kennedy to bring
populism to the Democrats now speaking
of the Biden Administration
Joe Biden's monkey pox Czar a man named
Dimitri Das galakis if you forget who he
is he's that guy who published
photographs of himself wearing leather
sex gear and specifically wore a leather
pentagram symbol of the devil on his
chest over a pentagram tattoo these are
the people
that are supposedly Catholic President
Staffing his administration with not so
I shouldn't laugh because it's pretty
dark but this guy this uh Satan
worshiping
leather Sex Fiend he uh he was put in
charge of monkey box which is kind of
funny too uh but he seems to have really
terrible advice for how to deal with
monkey pox because you would think if
you're in that role if you're the monkey
pox star
and you know that practically speaking
monkey pox is a sexually transmitted
disease for homosexual men who go to
orgies that's how it spreads
technically you can get it other ways
but that's in in effect that's actually
how it spreads you could call it gay
orgy pox sort of like with HIV they say
that HIV is not a sexually transmitted
disease because you can get it from
Needles like I guess you can but the way
you do get it is from a very specific
kind of sexual intercourse most of the
time so
uh this monkey box guy you would expect
him to say hey
don't engage in dangerous sexual
practices that should be pretty much the
only thing that his job requires and yet
and yet
he says the opposite I work in HIV
normally and I'll tell you that you know
I always say that I've never made an HIV
diagnosis in someone that hasn't somehow
related to stigma I think M pox is the
same so really um uh stigma tends to be
a barrier to testing a barrier to
vaccination and so you know really
addressing stigma intentionally and
making sure that we get the word out in
a way that supports people's joy as
opposed to you know calling them risky
so I think you know one of the things to
think about is that you know one
person's idea of risk is another
person's idea of a great festival or
Friday night for that matter so we have
to sort of embrace that with joy and
make sure that folks know how to keep
themselves safe
do we though do we have to do that
one person's idea of risk
of Contracting HIV or monkey pox or any
other number of sexually transmitted
diseases one man's idea of risk is
another guy's idea of a great Friday
night am I right am I right and so what
we have to do is encourage that
encourage people to go to weird leather
orgies we have to we have to what other
choice do we have what are we going to
tell them not to engage in dangerous
deviant sexual behavior that's obviously
depraved and wrong that's that societies
for all of history have discouraged
strongly and certainly our civilization
discouraged for pretty much its entire
existence would we do that
but but then we won't get the monkey pox
orgies and we can't tell people not to
go to those
I think we can
stigma stigma
is a real barrier to
people getting vaccines
maybe or something so that that may or
may not be true I'm not totally
convinced that's true
but you know what stigma is is also a
big impediment too
Contracting these illnesses do you know
what stigma is also a great impediment
to
orgies
and bath houses and weird monkey box
leather parties
stigma also suppresses those things
because they're considered socially
unacceptable sometimes they're
considered illegal if they happen there
can be legal consequences for it there
will be much more broadly cultural
consequences for it and fewer people
engage in that risky Behavior which the
monkey box guy admits is very bad for
people
not bad like you get the sniffles for a
couple weeks bad like you get HIV
can we can we just say no can we just
say no to this stuff he's honest in that
this guy this Satan worshiping leather
daddy monkey box are working for Joe
Biden is following liberalism to its
logical conclusion
The Logical conclusion that begins with
the skepticism of liberalism the idea
that we can't really know what's good or
bad or right or wrong or true or false
you know we're just going to try to get
along and be peaceful and increase our
material prosperity and tick up GDP a
little bit The Logical conclusion of
that is
hey one man's HIV orgy is another man's
fun Friday night so let's enjoy let's
encourage people's Joy
but of course
engaging in these deviant dangerous
destructive
practices sexual or otherwise will not
ultimately bring people Joy it might
bring them a disordered temporary sense
of euphoria but ultimately will bring
them misery
because when you do bad things that
makes you less happy in the long run and
when you do good things that makes you
more happy in the long run
this this is why by the way I cited a
survey yesterday from Gallup that said
that same-sex sexual relations
has decreased in acceptability in the
American consciousness so not just the
trans stuff not just even redefining
marriage
but even the idea of same-sex relations
people now view it less favorably than
they did a year or two ago
significantly so
why is that it's it's not because of
Will and Grace it's not because of your
gay cousin who's got you know a live-in
partner or something where they're
perfectly
Pleasant and appropriate and you know
have nice Thanksgiving dinner it's
because of that guy
it's and it's because of the teachers in
the public schools who are pushing this
radical ideology and it's because of
transiting the kids and it's it's
because people are seeing the logical
conclusion of the sexual Revolution they
say you know
we don't need to tolerate the monkey pox
orgies that's not what James Madison
wrote the Constitution for okay that's
not what the Declaration of Independence
is about the new one or the old one
we're
we're just not going to do it anymore
so you're seeing this in the schools
this was a story came out about a week
ago I did my best to avoid getting to
this story but I think we actually have
to get to it the clip is all over the
place and I've I've censored it
liberally so that you don't have to hear
too much of this gross lesson this is a
high school teacher in Southern
California giving a lesson on pleasing
an orifice of the body
you don't have to go inside you can
actually just push on the seam and that
stimulates the gland as well and that
all they apparently really like that
um but yeah so that's why for male and
male
is still very pleasurable because of the
fact that it hits the it hits and
there's a lot of nerve endings in your
beauty as well so the girls
prostate they're the equivalent to each
other but apparently that's why if you
ever see like
I become target has them now sex toys if
you go to Target seriously if you go to
Target and go where the tampons and pads
are they have they just look like a
little box but if you open up the
there's like a velcro front to the Box
you open it up and then bam sex toy okay
you get the idea there's more to the
video but you you can use your
imagination to fill in the blanks and
what else you're saying she's giving the
students this very graphic
instructive lesson
on how to engage in deviant sexual
practices that are not oriented towards
say the good of the spouses and the
generation in the education of children
traditionally understood as the T loss
of sexual relations the purpose of
sexual relations but on how to titillate
people in ways by putting things where
they're not supposed to go so
some parents are up in arms about this
the teacher has been placed on
administrative leave
but students are defending the teacher
a student said quote
as a student in the video I would like
to say that everything taught by our
teacher is educational this is an
anatomy physiology class
and people shouldn't put her on leave
and she should be rehired and I gotta
tell you oddly enough
I'm with the students
I'm kind of on the teacher's side here
this is a gross lesson it obviously
shouldn't be taught in high schools it
obviously shouldn't be taught a taxpayer
expense the kids are getting a bad
education here the woman is
bad at her job if her job is educating
people
but she's pretty good at her job if her
job is following the lesson plans that
her bosses set out
the woman is just doing the job that was
established by the school boards by the
state now when we're talking about
California
and by our culture more broadly
she's teaching a class on anatomy and
physiology we have classes on sexual
education
sexual education now no longer has a
moral aspect to it
in the traditional sense I guess it has
a moral aspect to it in the in the
immoral modern sense which is to say any
sexual behavior that you find
pleasurable is good that's a that's a
moral lesson it just happens to be
immoral and it teaches the the
immorality of liberalism rather than the
true morality of religion but
she's just following the lesson man
don't fire her
she's doing her job you should fire the
school board members you should in the
case of California you should fire the
state administrators over education and
the governor Gavin Newsom
but we can't get mad at the foot
soldiers for following the orders
if if you get mad at that you should say
maybe she should quit her job or
she probably doesn't know any better
the people who really deserve our ire
are the people who are setting the
lessons
and that includes the governors
that includes the state administrators
and that includes
the number of people often a very vocal
intense activist minority but sometimes
there's a significant number of them
people ordinary citizens who peddle this
stuff this is wrong if you don't want it
in your schools then you've got to vote
the bums out and then when whenever and
wherever you can wield political power
to take the power away from these
weirdos speaking of kids there's a major
Supreme Court case that not a lot of
people have been talking about but it's
a really heart-wrenching case over
whether
not white couples or black couples or
Hispanic couples I guess non-native
American couples can adopt Native
American children and whether tribes can
demand Native American children who've
been adopted
not be allowed to grow up in those
cultures and have to come back to the
plantation and
the conservatives are kind of split on
this issue
but it tells you a lot this case which
was very sadly decided tells you a lot
it shows you a big fault line in the
American right between liberalism and
conservatism now one thing that kids
need is a Cozy home and when you want
cozy bed sheets you got to check out
cozyearth.com use promo code Noel summer
is hot and sticky and that used to mean
kicking off your covers every single
night to try and stay cool that all
changes when you discover cozy Earth
bedding simply swap out your current
sheets for soft breathable temperature
regulating sheets from cozy Earth I love
cozy Earth I've got a beautiful
luxurious set of cozy Earth bedding and
I sleep like a baby their bedding is
made from viscose bamboo so it traps
less heat enabling people to sleep
cooler and more comfortably year round
cozy Earth's luxury bedding and
loungewear transforms lives by offering
the world's softest most luxurious and
responsibly sourced betting with an eye
toward quality responsible production
Cutting Edge technology and premium
materials cozy Earth selects only the
best suppliers they got a hundred night
guarantee on their sheets the brand has
over 5 000 5 Star reviews on their
website their sheets get softer and
softer with every wash I just love them
they are just phenomenal quality
strongly strongly recommend you check
them out so you can get a sense of what
it's like to be in my Boudoir I'm a
married man but you can sleep on cozy
Earth you'll get a good sense of it
invest today in a good night's sleep
when you sleep while your life goes well
for a limited time save forty four zero
percent off cozy Earth's betting
cozyearth.com promo code knows 40 off
promo code and also check out for up to
40 off your order at cozyearth.com
if you're looking for something really
interesting to watch you've got to check
out our series what we saw hosted by
Storyteller Bill Whittle season one is
focused on Apollo 11 and now the
entirety of season two of what we saw is
available right now delve into the
origins and key events if the Cold War
as the series explores pivotal moments
such as the Berlin blockade the Korean
War the death of Stalin the Cuban
Missile Crisis the Vietnam War Watergate
and the ultimate resolution of the Cold
War don't just read about history live
it Bill makes you feel like you are
their witnessing history all episodes of
Cold War are now available to stream but
you've got to be a daily wire plus
member to see it my favorite comment
yesterday from Julia T who says RFK Jr
and Trump would be an effing insane
combo I'd be on board key there being
insane
that's I think why a lot of people are
jammed up for it because if you just
think about politics and the way that
politics has been in America for 20 or
30 years now you say well that doesn't
make sense because RFK he's anti-second
amendment I think he's pro-abortion he's
a lib you know he's a big lib so why
would I vote for a lib
but if you if you think about politics
in in a little bit of a higher way like
a meta Politics the politics of politics
and you say okay hold on right now the
issues that are defining our political
debates are to some degree still these
these issues over I don't know say
abortion or immigration or the economy
or but
at a larger level the debates are over
how we are even governed who even gets
to decide those questions
because right now the Deep State you
know the bureaucrats the administrative
State the permanent government
they broadly decide a lot of those
questions especially on foreign policy
especially on things like trade and
the the elections are kind of kind of
rigged they seem kind of rigged right
now and neither party really has faith
in the elections among the rank and file
voters so
when you when you see the issues being
about a corrupt system then all of a
sudden these populist weirdo wrench in
the system candidates like Trump and RFK
Jr they start to make a little bit more
sense the fact that you say man that
would be effing insane
that is kind of the best argument for
that ticket
the the best argument for a trump
Kennedy ticket is not that they're the
most coherently cohesively conservative
patriotic whatever candidates that you
ever saw in the argument for that ticket
is that this machine of state that is
operating now has is very corrupt
and it's not responsive to the people
and it's not doing good things and so we
just need to throw these people who
don't fit into the machine and gum the
whole thing up
if that's what the election's about
Trump Kennedy is a pretty good ticket
so this is case
Holland versus brackeen I'm sure I'm I'm
mispronouncing that this is a challenge
the 1978 Indian Child Welfare act which
was created to maintain Native American
culture by prioritizing native families
in the adoption of native children
and the case was 7-2
the only people who voted
against the claims of the Indian tribes
to keep the kids even if the kids are
had been adopted by non-indian parents
the only ones to vote against that were
Alito and Thomas who were the two most
conservative judges on the court
the other the libs plus the other
conservatives they voted in favor of the
Indian Child Welfare Act
which prioritizes maintaining Native
American culture over the interests of
the Native American children and
obviously over the interests of the
non-native American families who have
adopted these children and there are all
sorts of legal rights that were involved
in in this decision
uh 10th Amendment rights you know states
rights the 14th Amendment right to equal
protection but
at a broader level this case
is a debate between liberalism and
Christian conservatism
because if you've got a debate
if you are on the side of liberalism
classical or otherwise if you were on
the side of nationalism which which
crops up at the same time as liberalism
this idea that Nations have a pretty
firmly absolute right to do whatever the
hell they want within their own
territories within their among their own
people if you believe that there are
plenty of conservatives who believe that
and they're sort of persuasive arguments
then you're going to side with the
Indians here you're going to side with
the Indian Child Welfare act you're
going to say the maintenance of Indian
culture feather not DOT is more
important than the welfare of any
individual Indian Child
however if you are on the side of
Christian conservatism you're going to
side with the Indian children here
against the Indian Child Welfare Act
because if you're on the side of
Christian conservatism you're probably
sympathetic to the particular claims of
a particular tribe and you you're not
opposed to them having their own culture
and traditions and practices but
more fundamentally you believe that
there are Eternal truths
you believe that you are called to
evangelize all of the Nations
and you believe that
your understanding of the truth has a
special claim all throughout the world
that we're not just going to live in
some relativistic hodgepodge of
individual cultures and Nations and you
can't judge my culture and I can't judge
your culture and stay out of my borders
man
if you're a traditional Christian
conservative conservative you're going
to say oh no
there is a God he's a Triune God he
loves us
we have the gospel message we've got a
good culture here and so we're not
necessarily going to be eager to go in
and Conquer you or you know make we're
not going to make you convert at
gunpoint or anything like that but if a
Native American family puts their kid up
for adoption we have to raise that kid
we baptized that kid then we are going
to continue to raise that kid and your
claims of cultural particularity or
whatever are not going to overcome the
claims of baptism and the gospel and the
the Western culture Christendom that
we're going to raise this child in
and it you're going to see conservatives
fall on both sides of this
there are plenty of strong conservative
Defenders of nationalism and even even
of Classical liberalism to some degree
but it is no coincidence that the I the
people who appear to be the most
conservative and I think the most
conservative and a Christian
conservative kind of way Alito and
Thomas they're the ones who come down on
the side of the kids
the others who are a little bit
a little bit more liberal a little bit
less hardcore they're the ones who side
with the actual Court liberals and and
side with the the Indian tribes
now speaking of young people great news
coming out of Gallup
it's a lot of great news on the horizon
about the American people even as the
American government seems to decay
Americans are overwhelmingly pro-life
according to a Gallup news survey
released this week
just 37 percent of Americans think
abortion should be legal in the second
or third trimester of pregnancy
only 22 percent believe that it should
be legal in the third trimester so well
over three quarters of Americans say you
you really should ban abortion in the
third trimester and about two-thirds say
that you should ban abortion in the
second trimester too so you've got at
least you know roughly two-thirds of
Americans who say abortion should only
be legal in the first trimester
now unfortunately
the majority of Americans believe
abortion should be legal in the first
three months of pregnancy that's 69 of
Americans so that's the highest
percentage since Gallup began tracking
the trend so you've now got you've got
more Americans than ever who think
abortion should be legal in the first
trimester but you've got a cratering
number of Americans who think that
abortion should be legal in the second
and third trimester
what does that tell us
I think it's basically good news in that
if you were able to ban abortion in
America in the second and third
trimester that would be a great
improvement over what we've got now so
I'll take it
but it also shows you one of the
downsides of democratic lowercase D
Democratic politics which is that it
tends toward incoherence
you ever hear about the independent
voter
in America in democracies we always
exalt the independent voter
but the independent voter
very often is independent because his
political views don't make any sense so
he'll say
I don't know he'll say I'm a pro
I'm Pro uh abortion
well I guess in this case you just say
I'm pro-abortion in the first trimester
but not in the third trimester it's the
same baby why is it okay to murder the
baby at one point but not another point
or you'll you'll see someone say
I'm in favor of transgenderism but not
for transiting the kids well okay if
you're in favor of transgenderism
then you're making a claim about human
nature
and if if that claim about human nature
is true it's true of the kids also
or you'll you'll see someone say
I'm in favor of uh
I don't know any any number of sort of
issues uh they'll they'll be a little
bit confused they'll support some social
policies but not certain economic
policies and it gets a little bit
jumbled up
now a nice consequence of the hostility
between the people and the elite that
we're seeing increasing
is that
Elite opinion
in this liberal establishment is pretty
reliably wrong on all of these issues on
sexuality on immigration on the economy
on foreign policy the elite opinion if
you open up the pages of the New York
Times The Washington Post you find
whatever the opinion is there you can 99
times out of 100 be confident that that
opinion is wrong and you should have the
opposite opinion
which means that
as the elites become more and more
radical more and more corrupt more and
more wrong and the people increasingly
view the elites as hostile to them
the American people are going to become
more conservative
as we're seeing reflected in the polls
on abortion on sexual matters on
education on even economic matters
on foreign policy uh you're seeing a
conservatizing of the American people
will that be reflected in the polls the
question is how much power do the people
have
we would get to member block
and I would blame
producer Jacob but I cannot I cannot
blame him right now I actually sent him
away
I've got to go to
Gavin Mussolini's hell hole of
California for just a few days we've got
some projects we're doing out there and
so
there's no member block today we'll join
you again for member block tomorrow I
will miss you in the meantime but until
then I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]